time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week according
to the American Heart Association every
40 seconds someone in the u.s. suffers a
heart attack that is a disturbing number
but a recent report shows that for older
Americans those numbers are actually
going down the study analyzed over 4.3
million Medicare fee-for-service
beneficiaries age 65 and older during a
19 year period from 1995 to 2014 looking
at the patterns of hospitalizations
treatments and outcomes for heart attack
patients here to discuss the findings
and more is CBS News medical contributor
dr. David agus David good morning when
do you so what did we learn here this is
pretty important data it shows over a
period of 20 years two decades the rate
of heart attacks hospitalizations how
people did at the hospitalizations
there's length of them and how many
people died went down dramatically
almost a third across the board so we
had the same treatments in general 20
years ago we're using them better we're
using the quicker and more appropriately
now this is big progress is it really
just devoted to that to those changes I
mean in terms of improvements oh no
question about it is that we we have
these algorithms of what to do and we're
implementing them very quickly the
quicker you act the more you can get
blood supply back to the heart when we
actually tell people the right thing to
do after a heart attack to prevent
another one you get a better outcome and
the system is working better now and
we're seeing it in the data how can they
be sure it's the system and not people
living healthier lives I think living a
healthy life is part of it we're
certainly smoking less as a nation over
the last two decades but when you look
at the numbers of the heart attacks and
the outcomes of the heart attacks
they're getting better and that's the
system doctor would you say that means
we can at 65 year old Americans drink
smoke and eat red meat more a hundred
percent I mean this is this is know if
it ain't broke don't fix it what we're
doing now is working we got to keep with
it and how about that baby aspirin baby
aspirin a day has a dramatic effect oh
come on stroke I know you're pushing me
here but I believe in it the data are
what the data are okay all right we've
been long with total the importance of
memory
and breast cancer screenings but now
some changes are on the way the Food and
Drug Administration has announced that
for the first time in 20 years the
agency will propose new protocols to
empower patients and improve the quality
of mammogram services David this is the
second leading cause of death among
women in America right so what exactly
is the FDA proposing so this is the
first time in two decades that they're
saying hey we're regulating mammography
mammogram centers we want to make it
better so the first thing which I think
is critical is about 40% of women over
the age of 40 have dense breast dense
breasts means you're slightly higher
risk for breast cancer and sometimes
it's harder for mammograms because the
denseness make the mammogram is white
they can't see the cancer in it and
they're saying you have to report it to
the patient what's going on that's
powerful so that doctors can read it and
just you know write something they now
have to explain it to the patient so
they will know their own risk having
been through this
more so than either of my my two young
men here or so but the question is is it
at all dangerous the number of times you
have mammograms mammograms are radiation
so it's putting energy through your
breast so there's no question there is a
small finite risk to getting a mammogram
but when we look at the data catching
breast cancer early saves lives the key
to the FDA here is they're regulating
quality so the quality of the center if
the center is not good either the center
the FDA will write you a letter saying
hey this Center wasn't good enough you
need to get tests elsewhere and now
actually telling the patient exactly
what's going on so they can maybe get
another set an ultrasound or MRI if
needed more than one in 10 women in
their lifetimes are likely to have a
cancer diagnosis for breast cancer what
can be done to bring that number down on
the front end ahead of the diagnosis
well I mean it's it's prevention right
it's being lean body mist it's knowing
your risk it's you know if you need to
take some medications that can actually
lower a risk but more than anything it's
it's screening here screening is
critical to catch it early and save
lives dr. David agus thank you so much
for being with us thank you all